Speaker 1: I want to start today as we have many
days in the last week and talk about the Russian
invasion of Ukraine, but I want to zoom out
a little bit and take a little bit more of a
systemic big picture, 30000 foot view. You know,
one of the goals of Vladimir Putin and Russia
for more than a decade now in earnest. And
you could argue really even longer than that
is to weaken what's seen as the West, the United
States and Europe. Or, you know, you could sort of
characterize it in a number of different ways
weaken the West, make the United States and
Western democracy look weaker or in question or
untrustworthy in some way. And the general goal
of this is to make Russia look better in
comparison. I mean, this is a very basic and sort
of crude way to say it. But when you think about
the three major superpowers the United States,
Russia and China, the worse any one of them looks,
the better by comparison, others look. And so when
we think back to the Trump era and we wonder or
we don't really have to wonder, but we think about
why Putin would want and benefited from Trump
rather than Hillary Clinton being president.
And chaos electorally in claims about voter fraud
and all these things. Why does Putin benefit from
that? Well, when you step back and look at the
three major powers, if the U.S. looks silly,
if the US look stupid, if the U.S. looks so
ignorant that there are enough people that they
would vote for a clown like Trump. By comparison,
it makes Russia look better. And one of the
main goals of Putin in general is to make the the
West and the U.S. look worse and the most the more
fragmented that the West is, the weaker that
it appears to be. And unfortunately for Putin,
his invasion of Ukraine has sort of accidentally
or as a side effect, unified and strengthened the
West to the extent that the West is now very
clear, with some exceptions. You know, you
turn on Fox News, you'll see appropriate pro-Putin
Apollonia. But for the most part, Putin's invasion
of Ukraine has actually had the unintended
consequence of unifying and strengthening the
West. There's an interesting article that you can
check out by Hollie Elliott on CNBC called Putin's
Always Wanted to Weaken the West. He's done the
exact opposite, and the article actually explains
If there's anything we've learned about
Putin over the 22 years he's been in power,
it's that he is systematically and repeatedly
tried to weaken and undermine the West. But in
his invasion of Ukraine, he seems to have achieved
the exact opposite, managing to unite most of the
international community in its condemnation
of Russia's aggression towards its neighbor.
Ian Bremmer, president of political risk
consultancy Eurasia Group, commented quote Naito
is united more so than at any point since the
Soviet collapse, with a renewed sense of purpose
and mission. So too is the European Union. Germany
supports ending their economic dependance on
Russia and is nearly doubling their defense spend.
France is on board, even Moscow tilting. Hungary
has condemned the invasion, favored a crippling
sanctions regime and is allowing in hundreds of
thousands of Ukrainian refugees refugees. The West
is used to Russia behaving like a malign actor.
Over time, it's also widely seen as responsible
for rather. It also sees Russia as responsible for
a nerve agent attack on UK soil in 2018 and was
subsequently sanctioned. And it goes on to explain
that this may have been, in a sense, the worst
unintended consequence of what Putin is doing now.
Putin may end up dead at the end of this entire
thing. We don't know. Putin may end up deposed out
of power. We don't know. Putin may end up taking
Ukraine. We don't know at this point in time.
But the way in which this has unified the West
over the long term is not particularly good
for Putin's bigger picture ambitions. Now there's
another aspect to this which we've seen at the
David Pakman show, and I've talked to some other
independent media people and everybody's seeing
the same thing over the last 10 to 14 days. There
has been a notable decline in a certain strain
of bot type right wing trolling all over our
platforms. I'm talking YouTube, Twitter, Reddit,
etc. There has been for the last many years a
suspicious amount of comments like I am as liberal
as the next guy, but and then they use some like
right wing argument to try to make it seem as
though even left wingers are skeptical. All of
the American left and all those different stuff,
you know, stuff like. Listen, I'm I'm a foreigner
and I just don't understand why is having needing
a photo ID such a bad thing for voting? You need
an ID for everything else. All these repetitive
sorts of messages that we see posted on all of
our platforms, they have diminished dramatically
in the last 10 to 14 days now. I don't think
it's because they are all Russian trolls,
but we know that Russia for a long time has waged
pretty slick sort of disinformation type campaigns
online all over the world, and shows like
ours have absolutely been affected by them.
If you look at any of our platforms. That is down
dramatically, it seems, because they are at least
to some degree preoccupied with trying to justify
this invasion of Ukraine. And the next months,
presumably will give us a sense of is Russia
heading towards annexing Ukraine or installing
a puppet government? Is Russia heading in the
opposite direction of going in the direction
of a truly failed state for a long time with a
broken economy? That remains to be seen. But Putin
succeeded at calling into question American
democracy when Trump won and then when they
fomented the Big Lie ideas that Trump won again
in 2020. Even though he didn't he? He succeeded
at that. He really did. But without a doubt, to
some degree, the biggest unintended unintended
consequence of the Russian invasion of Ukraine is
that much of the West is now as united as it has
been in a really, really long time. Putin may
end up taking Ukraine. We just don't know yet,
and I think anybody who leans on the inevitability
of one outcome or the other, there's people who
are saying, Listen, sooner or later, Putin is
going to get Ukraine. I don't think that that's
something we can accurately say. On the other
hand, you have the perspective that sooner or
later, Russia's going to get just absolutely
crushed here and Putin will be removed, killed,
whatever. I don't think that that's a foregone
conclusion, either. I don't think we know the
answer. But when you see the West, as united as it
is, it doesn't bode particularly well for Russia.